you wrote another screenplay American
Babylon mm-hmm which you won an award or
you wanted a grant me and what's the
screenplay about American Babylon takes
place in 2001 the summer of 2001 and it
follows 26 year-old exile from Chile I
don't know how he came up with it and he
he mostly just wants to ignore the world
around him and be happy and and be chill
and take care of his sick uncle who's a
ex revolutionary from Chile who is kind
of this if he recycles he builds crosses
for the church he stays that he's kind
of this hermit and uh the main character
also barters weed so he lives in this
underground economy but it's um
bartering and his girlfriend
Satya a black girl from Oakland he also
used to Berkeley studies history
she's a activist he's organizing a march
so she's always pushing him to care and
to get involved in the world around him
back in 2001 you know Bush had just
stolen the elections and Oakland was up
in arms and there was huge marches
against globalization so the world was
very active and so my film is like
dealing with that world and pushing our
main character to care but he avoids it
until his uncle gets sick he can't
afford it take care of him he's forced
to switch from bartering to selling weed
kind of breaking his his mode of
operating in the world eventually the
march of the girlfriend organizes riot
police shut it down it's a peaceful
march but she gets hit and arrested and
taken away for a while and all these
things trigger the main characters
memories of his parents being killed in
a dictatorship in Chile and so these
these dreams last night mares start
reoccurring and pushing him and he ends
up kind of breaking and joining the
group of his girlfriend and they all
decide to take an action and because of
his history they decide to they pick a
day for an action based on a day that
started the dictatorship and chillin and
eventually it becomes an argument
between them about doing a violent or
nonviolent action the girlfriend is
definitely about non-violence very much
like an MLK character and embodying that
ideology and the main character because
of his experience and his past cannot do
anything but do a violent act and it's
not about killing anybody but it's about
property destruction they pick a company
to had a history to his military coup
the US was heavily involved in a
military coup in Chile so the film is
like connecting these dots and
eventually they go into this it becomes
like a heist film and they go to do this
action there in a Plaza in San Francisco
with two big screens on both sides in
the financial district they get there's
a snitch they get surrounded by the
police guns drawn and 9/11 happens in
the screens and that's the film and it's
it's based on real history a lot of
people don't know it but the
dictatorship in Chile occurred on
September 11th 1973 so all my life and
all Chileans lives 9/11 has been a day
that we that we mourn or you celebrate
depends on what side you're on
but a day for sure that marks or history
and so when 9/11 happened here I was a
taxi right here in LA I I still get
chills like how is that possible and
they're very similar events I mean
there's airplanes bombing the National
Palace in Chile and airplanes hitting a
building here on a Tuesday in the
morning it's just like really weird so
it comes from a place of me having to
9/11 is in my life to kind of grapple
and to address this cycle of violence
you know like violence begets more
violence is a theme on my film and how
we one cannot have a historical amnesia
and not acknowledge what's happened in
the past because if we do things will
keep happening and we need to learn how
to deal with these things and a
healthier way that's kind of
my crazy family how long did it take you
to write that well the initial idea I
mean the ending came to me a few days
after 9/11 I mean I was like I have to
connect these but you know that's a long
time ago and then realistically two
years ago two and a half years ago I sat
down and wrote my first solid draft then
I applied to this a film's rain and
grant and I got a screenwriting grant
for that and since then I've been you
know I've done a few drafts I went to
this amazing lab called scenic one on
lab that takes place in Mexico small
towns seen some Sun with mentors and
it's 13 other filmmakers and really like
took my screenplay to a new level
yeah so it's been solid two and a half
years really working hard at it
yeah is it hard for you to work on it is
it does it bring up a good question
memories or sort of an anger I mean
that's the thing I had to realize that
this lab is that unconsciously I was
definitely protecting this character you
know he's not me but he's definitely
somebody who has a similar experience to
me I had both my parents thankfully so I
don't have the pain that he does but I
still was protecting him emotionally and
a screenplay in a movie you have to push
your characters to to feel you know to
go rock bottom and so yeah I've had to
open up you know my own personal fears
my own personal traumas to allow this
character to go there and yeah the
screenplays way better because of that
you know you have to allow yourself to
to feel and to yeah go to your dark side
is that something you would recommend to
other writers don't don't protect your
main character as close as as they may
feel absolutely I mean one of the main
lessons so the girlfriend is a genius
advice I got in you know there's this my
film is a story that has a huge
backstory that's not seen in the film I
his parents get assessing it which is
like the biggest emotionally back story
you can have character losses as parents
right
so an equivalent to that you have to
balance that out with the present film
other
why are you telling the president not
the past you know and so something just
as emotional needs to occur in your
present in the film it needs to happen
to this character that pain needs to
happen to this character
how do you achieve that you know how do
you achieve a trauma of a past to affect
the present so I'm not doing this but
our recommendation or a logical
deduction of that is I have to kill the
girlfriend all right like somebody has
to die the uncle I said I somebody has
to kill but even if you're not going to
make that choice as a writer because you
don't feel it's right you have to try it
and by doing so by pushing to the edge
by killing somebody and one of your
characters you're gonna learn what you
need to do what you miss what what you
can gain from that it kind of experiment
and so I highly recommend when you're
dealing with highly emotional things -
yeah push it to the limit not as it's
just a gimmick but to learn what this
does to your character into your story
and I help me a lot to kill her for like
three days she comes back to life
now she'll go down I said I I practice I
worked out the film in a way what
happens if she does get killed you know
like what does that mean to the Cure
what does that trigger and how that can
I I don't want to tell you but how does
that how can you achieve a symbolic
death in a way you know that's what I
had to do is figure out a way that she
in a way dies but not essa
you